Hi there, Shankar here. In these last few weeks, we've looked at social science research that can help us lead fuller lives, that can improve the decisions we make. These episodes are part of a series that we call U2.0. This week, we bring back one of our favorite stories. It's about how we often tune out, at the very times, we need to pay attention. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
你好，我是尚卡尔。在过去的几周里，我们研究了社会科学研究，这些研究可以帮助我们过上更充实的生活，改善我们所做的决定。这些剧集是我们称之为 U2.0 系列的一部分。本周，我们带回了我们最喜欢的故事之一。它讲述了我们如何在最需要关注的时候，却往往选择置之不理。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Maybe your mornings sound like this. You wake up to your alarm ringing, you turn it off and bring your phone back to bed with you. You scroll through email and social media, squinting through one eye to see what you've got to get done and what's happening in the news. When you finally get up and start getting ready, maybe you have some music going or your favorite TV channel. And we continue to follow that breaking news and sounds.
也许你的早晨是这样的：你在闹钟声中醒来，关掉闹钟，把手机带回床上。你眯着一只眼睛浏览电子邮件和社交媒体，看看有什么必须完成的事情，以及新闻里发生了什么。当你终于起床开始准备时，也许你会放些音乐或打开你最喜欢的电视频道。我们继续关注那些突发新闻和声音。
Many of us are voracious consumers of information, and we're always looking for new ways to take an even more. Alexa, what's the weather today? In Charlotte, North Carolina, it's 63 degrees with mostly sunny skies. But even as we savor good news about the weather or the stock market or weekend plans, we're also regularly confronted by staff that's unpleasant. To listen to your unread voicemails, press one. Unpleasant information creates a paradox for the brain.
我们许多人都是贪婪的信息消费者，总是寻找新的方式来获取更多信息。“Alexa，今天天气怎么样？”“在北卡罗来纳州夏洛特市，气温 63 度，大部分时间是晴天。”但即使我们享受关于天气、股市或周末计划的好消息，我们也经常面临令人不快的事情。“要收听未读语音邮件，请按 1。”令人不快的信息为大脑制造了一个悖论。
This kind of information is often very important. First message. This is the principal calling from your son's school. Please contact us so we can arrange a time to discuss your son's behavior. But this kind of information also produces psychic pain. And one of the oldest rules in the brain is to avoid things that are painful.
这类信息通常非常重要。“第一条信息。我是你儿子学校的校长。请联系我们，以便我们安排时间讨论你儿子的行为。”但这类信息也会产生心理痛苦。大脑中最古老的规则之一就是避免痛苦的事情。
Second message. This is a doctor's office. Your test results have come in. Please call us back immediately. The tension between what we rationally know to be important and what we emotionally experience as painful is a subject of our episode today. Third message.
“第二条信息。我是医生办公室。你的检查结果出来了。请立即回电。”我们在理性上认为重要的事情与我们在情感上体验到的痛苦之间的张力，是我们今天这一集的主题。“第三条信息。”
Hey, just call me back to see if you get this. I'm okay. I saw your real wife kiss somebody. Sorry. Just give me a call. It's about why we sometimes... Message deleted. Message deleted. Shattered all out. Why we look away and the consequences of doing so?
“嘿，回电给我，看你有没有收到这个。我没事。我看到你老婆亲了别人。抱歉。给我打个电话。”这是关于我们有时为什么……“信息已删除。信息已删除。”全部删除了。为什么我们选择移开视线，以及这样做会带来什么后果？
This week on Hidden Brain. away and the consequences of doing so this week on Hidden Brain. There's an all theory in economics about information. It goes like this. You should always be willing to hear information about your finances or your health. For example, Hey Antonio, I help yourself to anything in the fridge but heads up sniff the milk first. I think it's getting close to the expiration date. Maybe this information is useful. Maybe it's not.
本周在《隐藏的大脑》中。移开视线，以及这样做会带来什么后果，本周在《隐藏的大脑》中。经济学中有一个关于信息的古老理论。它是这样的：你应该总是愿意听取关于你的财务或健康的信息。例如，“嘿，安东尼奥，冰箱里的东西随便吃，但先提醒一下，先闻闻牛奶。我觉得它快过期了。”也许这些信息是有用的。也许不是。
Oh, I'm fine. I'm actually like tocentolerant. No matter how you feel about the information, there's one thing you should never do. Person should never avoid information, because information can never hurt a decision. This is Josh Tassoff. I'm a assistant professor of economics at a Claremont graduate university. Josh says less is never more when it comes to information. We always should want to know if our 401k is about to take a nose dive or if we're at risk of contracting a disease. But here's the thing, humans aren't always rational.
“哦，我很好。其实我乳糖不耐受。”无论你对这些信息感觉如何，有一件事你永远不应该做。人永远不应该回避信息，因为信息永远不会损害决策。这是乔什·塔索夫。我是克莱蒙特研究生大学的经济学助理教授。乔什说，在信息方面，少绝不是多。我们总是应该想知道我们的 401k 养老金账户是否即将暴跌，或者我们是否有感染疾病的风险。但问题是，人类并不总是理性的。
And when it comes to information, what do we do when something makes us sad or depressed? We turn away from it. When the thing that's depressing is information, we say, I don't want to hear about it. Social scientists call this behavior information a version. More commonly, it's called the ostrich effect. The term comes not from birds, but investors. So, when the stock market goes down, people check their portfolio less frequently than when the stock market is going up.
当涉及到信息时，当我们感到悲伤或沮丧时，我们会怎么做？我们避开它。当令人沮丧的事情是信息时，我们会说：“我不想听。”社会科学家称这种行为为“信息厌恶”。更常见的说法是“鸵鸟效应”。这个词不是来自鸟类，而是来自投资者。所以，当股市下跌时，人们检查投资组合的频率比股市上涨时要低。
And why would that be? Well, the interpretation is that the information causes sort of immediate pain just from hearing it, right? People are anticipating sort of their future losses. Of course, they don't actually have any losses yet, but they're anticipating those future losses and that causes an emotional pain, obtaining that information. Information of Russian is one of many, many domains where human behavior seems to deviate
那为什么会这样呢？嗯，解释是，仅仅听到这些信息就会产生一种即时的痛苦，对吧？人们在预判他们未来的损失。当然，他们实际上还没有任何损失，但他们在预判那些未来的损失，而获取这些信息会造成情感上的痛苦。信息厌恶是人类行为似乎偏离经济学家模型的众多领域之一。
from the models of economists. Instead of doing the rational thing, learning as much as possible about something, many of us do the opposite. We stick our heads in the sand. And this is true for more than just financial information. A couple of months ago, we asked hidden Brain listeners to call in and tell us about their news consumption.
而不是做理性的事情，即尽可能多地了解某件事，我们许多人却做了相反的事情。我们把头埋在沙子里。这不仅适用于财务信息。几个月前，我们请《隐藏的大脑》的听众打来电话，告诉我们他们的新闻消费情况。
Hi Annie here. Hello, my name is Nancy Walter. Hi, Shaggy. This is Jason Flakes. Jason, Nancy and Annie are all addicted to the news. My husband and I are news junkies. I love listening to the news every day. Checking it every few hours.
“嗨，我是安妮。”“你好，我叫南希·沃尔特。”“嗨，尚卡尔。我是杰森·弗莱克斯。”杰森、南希和安妮都对新闻上瘾。“我和我丈夫是新闻迷。我喜欢每天听新闻。每隔几个小时就查看一次。”
Or at least, they were addicted to the news until Donald Trump caught them by surprise and won the 2016 presidential election. I had an anticipated Donald Trump winning. So I went on a complete news blackout. It's because of the frustration that I was feeling. And actually, I had a lot of anxiety because of it. I have dramatically changed the way.
或者至少，在唐纳德·特朗普让他们措手不及并赢得 2016 年总统大选之前，他们对新闻上瘾。“我没预料到唐纳德·特朗普会赢。所以我完全屏蔽了新闻。这是因为我感到的沮丧。实际上，我因此感到非常焦虑。我彻底改变了我阅读新闻的方式。”
I read the news following the election. These listeners had their fingers on the pulse of political news before the election, when Hillary Clinton appeared to be poised for victory. But in the days and weeks after Trump's surprising win, Jason, Nancy and Annie began to avoid the news. It was like the investors who stare lovingly at their portfolios when the stock markets on the rise, but avoid looking whenever the market dips. Headlines about the Trump administration stress these listeners out.
选举后。在选举前，当希拉里·克林顿看起来胜券在握时，这些听众对政治新闻了如指掌。但在特朗普令人惊讶的胜利后的几天和几周里，杰森、南希和安妮开始回避新闻。这就像那些在股市上涨时深情地盯着投资组合，但只要市场下跌就避免查看的投资者一样。关于特朗普政府的头条新闻让这些听众感到压力。
It caused them pain. And that's a key marker of information aversion. Now there are times when people avoid information when it's simply too much to digest. Let's say you're studying for a big test and after hours and hours of reading, you close your textbooks and take a break. This is information overload. You're burnt out from taking in so much stuff. With information aversion, the driver isn't that there's too much information, it's
这给他们带来了痛苦。这是信息厌恶的一个关键标志。现在，有时人们在信息太多无法消化时会回避信息。假设你正在为一场大考学习，经过几个小时的阅读，你合上课本休息一下。这是信息过载。你因为摄入太多东西而精疲力竭。而对于信息厌恶，驱动因素不是信息太多，而是
that the information is unpleasant. If you would tell these people about pleasant things, they'd be glad to listen all day. People want more information about happier future experiences than less happy future experiences. Josh wanted to see how much people prefer happy information to unpleasant information. He wanted to test that age-old theory. You should always be willing to hear information about your finances or your health. So he teamed up with a colleague. I'm Ananda Ganguly.
信息令人不快。如果你告诉这些人令人愉快的事情，他们会很高兴听一整天。人们想要更多关于未来快乐经历的信息，而不是未来不快乐经历的信息。乔什想看看人们在多大程度上更喜欢快乐的信息而不是不愉快的信息。他想测试那个古老的理论：你应该总是愿意听取关于你的财务或健康的信息。所以他与一位同事合作。“我是阿南达·甘古利。”
I met Claremont McKenna College. And the asked participants to come in and sit at a desk for 20 minutes. And posted in at their cubicle, in front front of them were two envelopes, one labeled big and one labeled small. They told the volunteers that there was a 10% chance the envelopes were filled with cash. But if the big envelope contains money, it contains $100. If the small envelope contains money, it contains $10. The volunteers would get to open the envelopes at the end of 20 minutes and pocket the contents. Now if 20 minutes was too long to wait, Josh and Ananda said the volunteers could pay
“我在克莱蒙特麦肯纳学院。”他们要求参与者进来，在桌子旁坐 20 分钟。在他们面前的隔间里放着两个信封，一个标着“大”，一个标着“小”。他们告诉志愿者，信封里装有现金的几率为 10%。但如果大信封里有钱，里面就是 100 美元。如果小信封里有钱，里面就是 10 美元。志愿者可以在 20 分钟结束时打开信封并装进口袋。现在，如果 20 分钟太长，乔什和阿南达说志愿者可以付钱
money to open one of the envelopes immediately. 83.4% paid money to affect the timing. Did you actually, actually physically observe the volunteers? Did you notice anything as they were dealing with this? Could you actually see the dilemma on their faces? Yeah, they were in a computer lab and doing this. And absolutely, I mean, it was almost like in a casino. But immediately they would start tearing the envelopes open and immediately I'm very excited about it and you know F-words would fly.
立即打开其中一个信封。83.4% 的人付钱来改变时间。“你们真的观察了志愿者吗？在他们处理这件事时，你们注意到了什么吗？你们能看到他们脸上的困境吗？”“是的，他们在计算机实验室里做这件事。绝对的，我的意思是，这几乎就像在赌场里。但他们会立即开始撕开信封，而且非常兴奋，你知道，脏话会脱口而出。”
And would F-words fly once they'd open the envelopes or before? After they open the envelopes it's the disappointment or the surprise. Here's the trick in the experiment. Remember that there were two envelopes, one big, one small. Big envelopes carry the potential of a big sum of money. Small envelopes carry the potential of a small sum of money. You can guess which ones the volunteers wanted to open. What we find is that people are twice as likely to open up the big envelope over the small envelope. The interpretation is that winning $100 is a lot more happy and a lot more exciting than winning $10.
“脏话是在他们打开信封后还是之前？”“在他们打开信封后，那是失望或惊喜。”实验的诀窍在这里。记住有两个信封，一个大，一个小。大信封有装大笔钱的潜力。小信封有装小笔钱的潜力。你可以猜到志愿者想打开哪一个。我们发现人们打开大信封的可能性是打开小信封的两倍。解释是，赢得 100 美元比赢得 10 美元要快乐得多，也令人兴奋得多。
And so people's demand for that information, even though it's completely useless in their decision making is much higher. I'm not sure I fully followed that. Walk me through that again. Well, the information here is completely useless for making any decisions. So no matter what, they're going to get this money or not get the money, right? They're just going to sit there for 20 minutes. And so receiving this information, unlike other decisions in our life, like, you know, good thinking in our daily life, if you're going to get a raise or anything like this,
因此，人们对这些信息的需求，即使它在决策中完全没用，也要高得多。“我不确定我完全理解了。再给我讲一遍。”嗯，这里的信息对于做任何决定完全没用。所以无论如何，他们都会得到这笔钱或得不到这笔钱，对吧？他们只是要在那里坐 20 分钟。所以接收这些信息，不像我们生活中的其他决定，比如，你知道，我们日常生活中的深思熟虑，如果你要加薪或类似的事情，
that information can be very useful because I'll help you improve your purchase decisions right now in the present. But here, they're basically stuck sitting in the lab in a seat. And so receiving this information 20 minutes earlier is completely useless. They can't use it to make any any decisions in that short interim period. Even if receiving the information earlier was useless, lots of volunteers were perfectly willing to pay to find out what was inside the envelope sooner. The bigger the potential good news, the more likely volunteers were to pay.
这些信息可能非常有用，因为它们会帮助你改善现在的购买决定。但在这里，他们基本上被困在实验室的座位上。所以提前 20 分钟接收这些信息是完全没用的。他们无法在那个短暂的过渡期内利用它做出任何决定。即使提前接收信息是没用的，许多志愿者也完全愿意付钱来更早地知道信封里有什么。潜在的好消息越大，志愿者付钱的可能性就越大。
The studies show that people are hungry for information when information is pleasant. Now there's one important detail we haven't told you yet. The amount of volunteers had to pay wasn't very much, just 50 cents to open an envelope. Since the big envelope could hold as much as $100, you might say that paying 50 cents was a trivial cost. We wanted to look at something that had greater real-world stakes. We know people want pleasant information, but are they willing to pay to avoid unpleasant news like information about a disease? Josh and Ananda decided to find out. They
研究表明，当信息令人愉快时，人们对信息如饥似渴。现在有一个我们还没告诉你的重要细节。志愿者必须支付的金额并不多，只需 50 美分就可以打开一个信封。由于大信封里可能装有 100 美元，你可能会说支付 50 美分是一个微不足道的成本。我们想看看在现实世界中风险更大的事情。我们知道人们想要令人愉快的信息，但他们愿意付钱来避免像疾病信息这样令人不快的新闻吗？乔什和阿南达决定一探究竟。他们
thought about the health concerns you might see on a college campus. The sample that we have access to are college undergrads, right? And so we could do something like a cancer test, but I don't think college undergrads, right? And so we could do something like a cancer test, but I don't think college undergrads are terribly concerned about that. I think what college undergrads tend to be typically concerned about is STDs. STDs sexually transmitted diseases. One of the most stigmatized and common diseases on college campuses is herpes. It's caused by the herpes' simplex virus or HSV. We chose HSV because the rate of prevalence of HSV in this population is rather high.
想到了你在大学校园里可能会看到的健康问题。“我们能接触到的样本是大学本科生，对吧？所以我们可以做类似癌症测试的事情，但我认为大学本科生……”“所以我可以做类似癌症测试的事情，但我认为大学本科生并不太担心那个。我认为大学本科生通常担心的是性传播疾病。”性传播疾病。大学校园里最受污名化和最常见的疾病之一是疱疹。它是由单纯疱疹病毒或 HSV 引起的。我们选择 HSV 是因为该人群中 HSV 的患病率相当高。
Rough numbers are around 50% chances or every other person has it, so they would have it. The other attractive thing about HSV for us is that this kind of two levels, kind of parallel, a $10 and $100 thing. There's Herpes Simplex virus 1 and Herpes Simplex virus 2. Herpes Simplex virus 1 is typically associated with cold source, and Herpes Simplex virus 2 is typically associated with general Herpes. HSB 1 is the oral Herpes Simplux virus 2 is typically associated with general Herpes. HSV1, it's the oral Herpes, is less considered to be less severe or less stigmatic or whatever in the population. Ananda and Josh ask collage students to come back to their lab.
“粗略数字大约是 50% 的几率，或者每两个人中就有一个人有，所以他们会有。HSV 对我们来说另一个吸引人的地方是，这种有两种水平，有点平行，10 美元和 100 美元的东西。有单纯疱疹病毒 1 型和单纯疱疹病毒 2 型。单纯疱疹病毒 1 型通常与唇疱疹有关，单纯疱疹病毒 2 型通常与生殖器疱疹有关。HSV 1 是口腔疱疹，单纯疱疹病毒 2 型通常与生殖器疱疹有关。HSV1，它是口腔疱疹，被认为在人群中严重程度较低或污名化较少。”阿南达和乔什请大学生回到他们的实验室。
This time, volunteers were asked to sit through a webinar about Herpes. We actually give them photographs of sores on the lips and photographs of sores on male and female genitalia, with a discussion of HSV1 and HSV2. And these pictures were graphic? These pictures were very graphic. In fact, we don't know that we'll be able to, we want to put it in the paper. They were completely clinical graphic. Since Josh and Ananda knew that some people avoid getting tested for herpes because they
这一次，志愿者被要求参加一个关于疱疹的网络研讨会。“我们实际上给他们看了嘴唇上溃疡的照片和男性及女性生殖器上溃疡的照片，并讨论了 HSV1 和 HSV2。”“这些照片很直观吗？”“这些照片非常直观。事实上，我们不知道我们是否能够，我们想把它写进论文里。它们是完全临床直观的。”由于乔什和阿南达知道有些人避免进行疱疹检测是因为他们
don't want to deal with a blood test, volunteers were told they had to have their blood drawn in order to stay in the study. The researchers told volunteers they could have the blood tested for free for both kinds of herpes. Volunteers were assured confidentiality. They were allowed to call into the lab with their initials and four randomly selected numbers of their own choice. Even the doctor would not know who they were. So, to recap, students were given graphic information about two forms of herpes. The researchers then proceeded to eliminate all the usual reasons someone might not want to get tested for the sexually transmitted disease. It was mandatory for the volunteers to get their blood drawn.
不想处理验血，志愿者被告知他们必须抽血才能留在研究中。研究人员告诉志愿者，他们可以免费检测两种疱疹。志愿者被保证保密。他们被允许用他们的首字母和自己选择的四个随机数字致电实验室。即使医生也不会知道他们是谁。所以，总结一下，学生们获得了关于两种疱疹的直观信息。研究人员随后着手消除了某人可能不想进行性传播疾病检测的所有常见原因。志愿者必须抽血是强制性的。
The test was free and the results would be obtained confidentially. Would volunteers elect to find out if they had herpes? Or would they choose to bury their heads in the sand? To test for information aversion, the researchers told the volunteers that they would have to pay $10 to not get their blood tested, a significant number of volunteers elected to pay this money. And just as the researchers had expected, volunteers were more likely to pay money to avoid getting highly unpleasant information about genital herpes than the less unpleasant information
检测是免费的，结果将保密获得。志愿者会选择找出他们是否患有疱疹吗？还是他们会选择把头埋在沙子里？为了测试信息厌恶，研究人员告诉志愿者，他们必须支付 10 美元才能不进行验血，相当多的志愿者选择支付这笔钱。正如研究人员所预料的那样，志愿者更有可能付钱来避免获得关于生殖器疱疹的高度不愉快的信息，而不是关于口腔疱疹的较不愉快的信息。
about oral herpes. Tell me about those people. So, they just said that that happened in front of them or how did that happen? So the phlebotomist drew the blood and we said, OK, so this was your choice. You had chosen not to be tested. So now this blood would be discarded.
“告诉我那些人。所以，他们只是说那发生在他们面前，或者那是怎么发生的？”“所以抽血师抽了血，我们说，好吧，所以这是你的选择。你选择了不进行检测。所以现在这些血将被丢弃。”
Would you please drop it down the sink and wash it out? And they did. They did. They would drop the tube into the sink and turn on the faucet and it would go. I mean at some level that has to be a little bit disturbing, right? The idea that you're drawing blood and throwing it down the sink? Yes, absolutely.
“请把它倒进水槽并洗掉好吗？”“他们照做了。他们照做了。他们会把试管扔进水槽，打开水龙头，它就流走了。”“我的意思是，在某种程度上，这一定有点令人不安，对吧？抽了血却把它扔进水槽的想法？”“是的，绝对是。”
And that's kind of the point here, though. So they are going to have the blood drawn. So you'd rather pay money, waste that blood, then know what your test results were. Did any of the students give you verbal feedback about what happened and their impressions of it? Did any of them explain why they declined to be tested? I mean, they obviously must have thought about what the implications were as they made the choice.
“但这正是这里的重点。所以他们要抽血。所以你宁愿付钱，浪费那些血，也不愿知道你的检查结果。有没有学生给你关于发生了什么以及他们的印象的口头反馈？有没有人解释他们为什么拒绝检测？我的意思是，他们在做出选择时显然一定考虑过后果。”
Oh, yeah. So, as we actually asked them them what was your motivation? 85.7%, the most common explanation was because, quote, it will cause me unnecessary stress or anxiety if I test positive. It's worth pointing out that lots of students elected to receive the information about whether they had herpes. In fact, a majority of students elected to do the rational thing and get their blood tested.
“哦，是的。所以，当我们实际上问他们动机是什么时，85.7%，最常见的解释是，引用，‘如果我检测呈阳性，这会给我造成不必要的压力或焦虑。’值得指出的是，许多学生选择接收关于他们是否患有疱疹的信息。事实上，大多数学生选择做理性的事情并进行验血。”
But that isn't surprising. The surprising thing is that that number wasn't 100% because... You should always be willing to hear information about your finances or your health. As many as 20% of the students were willing to pay cold, hard cash to avoid finding out that they had genital herpes. Another thing the researchers found, students who were in a good mood were more likely to avoid finding out that they had genital herpes. Another thing the researchers found, students who were in a good mood were more likely to avoid information than those in a bad mood. This may seem surprising, but it actually makes complete sense. When you're in a good mood, do you really want to ruin how you feel by discovering you have herpes?
“但这并不令人惊讶。令人惊讶的是这个数字不是 100%，因为……”“你应该总是愿意听取关于你的财务或健康的信息。”多达 20% 的学生愿意支付真金白银来避免发现他们患有生殖器疱疹。研究人员发现的另一件事是，心情好的学生更有可能避免发现他们患有生殖器疱疹。研究人员发现的另一件事是，心情好的学生更有可能避免信息，而不是心情不好的学生。这看起来可能令人惊讶，但实际上完全说得通。当你心情好时，你真的想通过发现自己患有疱疹来破坏你的感觉吗？
It's like an ignorance is bliss result. Think for a moment about the implications of information aversion. So many health and well-being messages are premenced on the idea that people will act rationally when it comes to preserving their health. What if that isn't true for a sizable number of people? I think that we should consider whether scare tactics in advertising and things like that. I mean, whether that is a good technique to encourage people to get tested or not is questionable. When we come back, we're going to leave the lab and head out into the real world to see how information a version plays out in everyday life.
这就像“无知是福”的结果。花点时间思考一下信息厌恶的含义。太多的健康和福祉信息都是基于人们在维护健康时会理性行事的想法。如果这对相当多的人来说不是真的呢？我认为我们应该考虑广告中的恐吓策略等是否可取。我的意思是，这是否是鼓励人们进行检测的好方法是有疑问的。当我们回来时，我们将离开实验室，走向现实世界，看看信息厌恶在日常生活中是如何表现的。
Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's no question that fear is an effective way to change how people behave. When a parent tells a kid to fall in line or risk losing iPad privileges for a week, or when a boss tells an employee to come into work on time or risk getting fired, these often produce the desired effect. We use scare tactics and public service announcements all the time, like in this road safety commercial from Thailand,
请继续收听。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。毫无疑问，恐惧是改变人们行为的有效方式。当父母告诉孩子要听话，否则冒着失去一周 iPad 使用权的风险，或者当老板告诉员工要准时上班，否则冒着被解雇的风险时，这些通常会产生预期的效果。我们一直在公共服务公告中使用恐吓策略，比如泰国这个道路安全广告，
where a speeding car runs into a group of pedestrians, or this anti-smoking advertisement from Poland, where a lit cigarette is transformed into a candle at the base of a tombstone. In Josh and Ananda's study, the majority of volunteers chose to get tested after being exposed to graphic images of her piece. This makes sense, says University of Illinois Psychology professor Dolores Alborassin. If you induce a significant level of fear, you're going to get a comparable reaction on the
超速行驶的汽车撞向一群行人，或者波兰这个反吸烟广告，点燃的香烟变成了墓碑底部的蜡烛。在乔什和阿南达的研究中，大多数志愿者在接触到疱疹的直观图像后选择了进行检测。伊利诺伊大学心理学教授多洛雷斯·阿尔博拉辛说，这说得通。如果你诱导了显著水平的恐惧，你会在行为方面得到相应的反应。
behavioral side. Dolores in a team of researchers analyzed 250 studies done about the effectiveness of fear in transforming behavior. While the research shows fear indeed is effective, Dolores says it has limitations. It does work better for one-time behaviors, so getting vaccinated, if I have a threat and there is an effective vaccine right after, and I just go in and get it one time. That's a easy to do. The behavior is done right after you experience the emotion, emotions are not that long lasting so it's gonna have an effect. But if it comes down to
多洛雷斯和一组研究人员分析了 250 项关于恐惧在改变行为方面有效性的研究。虽然研究表明恐惧确实有效，但多洛雷斯说它有局限性。“它对一次性行为更有效，比如接种疫苗，如果我面临威胁，紧接着有一种有效的疫苗，我只是进去接种一次。这很容易做到。行为在体验情绪后立即完成，情绪不会持续那么久，所以它会有效果。但如果归结为……”
following the right diet, we all know how difficult that is and whatever fear you might experience at one point is gone the next day. This is the crux of the issue. If you want someone to do something one time, frightening them into doing it could be very effective. But if you want them to do something regularly and over a long period of time, fear might not be effective. In fact, some research suggests it could be counterproductive. Let me just have you start if you don't mind by just introducing yourself and tell me your name.
“遵循正确的饮食，我们都知道那有多难，无论你在某一点上可能经历什么恐惧，第二天就消失了。”这是问题的症结所在。如果你想让某人做一次某事，吓唬他们去做可能非常有效。但如果你想让他们长期定期做某事，恐惧可能并不有效。事实上，一些研究表明它可能是适得其反的。“如果你不介意的话，让我先请你介绍一下自己，告诉我你的名字。”
Sure. My name is Ritesh Banjaj. I'm an economist. A few years ago, Ritesh and his colleague, Julius Zanella, began looking at data about 3,000 American women who all worked at a large company. All the women were between the ages of 50 and 64 and they were all covered by an insurance plan that provided a free mammogram every year. Which is perceived to be an important tool in the fight against breast cancer. This company made a real push to help women get screened for breast cancer. It would automatically schedule mammograms for staffers,
“当然。我叫里特什·班贾。我是一名经济学家。”几年前，里特什和他的同事朱利叶斯·扎内拉开始查看关于 3000 名在美国一家大公司工作的女性的数据。所有女性年龄都在 50 到 64 岁之间，她们都参加了一项每年提供免费乳房 X 光检查的保险计划。这被认为是抗击乳腺癌的重要工具。这家公司确实推动帮助女性进行乳腺癌筛查。它会自动为员工安排乳房 X 光检查，
and then remind women about upcoming appointments. Screenings were conducted right at the company, so they were easy to get to, and the wait times were minimal. In other words, many of the barriers that keep women from getting tested were absent at this company. Ritesh wanted to find out how the decisions of women to get screened for breast cancer were shaped by information aversion. He obtained detailed information from the company about employees, including their health status, and where they physically sat in relation to one another. He discovered that when one staffer was diagnosed with breast cancer, this dramatically changed
然后提醒女性即将到来的预约。筛查就在公司进行，所以很容易到达，等待时间也很短。换句话说，许多阻碍女性进行检测的障碍在这家公司都不存在。里特什想找出女性进行乳腺癌筛查的决定是如何受到信息厌恶影响的。他从公司获得了关于员工的详细信息，包括她们的健康状况，以及她们在物理位置上彼此的相对位置。他发现，当一名员工被诊断出患有乳腺癌时，这极大地改变了
the behavior of other women who walked in her vicinity. We find that on average, when a woman is diagnosed with breast cancer, her co-workers, her immediate co-workers, female co-workers, reduce their propensity to have a breast screening in the year in which the diagnosis takes place. And this impact is persistent for at least two more years after the diagnosis for that woman. Women in the closest proximity to the woman who was diagnosed with breast cancer,
在她附近工作的其他女性的行为。“我们发现，平均而言，当一名女性被诊断出患有乳腺癌时，她的同事，她的直接同事，女性同事，会降低她们在诊断发生的那一年进行乳房筛查的倾向。这种影响在诊断后的至少两年内对该女性持续存在。”与被诊断出患有乳腺癌的女性距离最近的女性，
learn of this information, their willingness to screen falls the most. Rathesh found that the severity of the disease was key. Women who had a coworker diagnosed with early stage breast cancer were less likely to skip their annual screenings. But if a woman had a more aggressive case of breast cancer, her colleagues were the ones who were more likely to skip the screenings. So it appears in our data that in groups where the stage of the cancer is late stage, so not an earlier stage of cancer,
得知这一信息后，她们进行筛查的意愿下降得最厉害。里特什发现疾病的严重程度是关键。有同事被诊断出患有早期乳腺癌的女性不太可能跳过年度筛查。但如果一名女性患有更具侵袭性的乳腺癌，她的同事反而更有可能跳过筛查。“所以我们的数据显示，在癌症处于晚期，而不是早期阶段的群体中，我们观察到的回避行为更强烈。”
the avoidance behavior that we are observing is stronger. Women who knew a coworker who was dying from breast cancer were the most likely to skip their mammograms. Seeing a colleague suffer may have frightened these women from obtaining information about their own health. Not long ago, I was playing sports with a friend on a weekend. I was trying to change directions quickly when my ankle gave out from under me. I felt a sharp pain and collapsed. In a matter of moments, my ankle started to swell up. It was like watching a balloon inflate.
认识一位因乳腺癌去世的同事的女性最有可能跳过乳房 X 光检查。看到同事受苦可能吓坏了这些女性，使她们不敢获取关于自己健康的信息。不久前，我周末和朋友一起运动。我试图快速改变方向时，脚踝从下面滑脱了。我感到一阵剧痛并倒下了。片刻之间，我的脚踝开始肿胀。就像看着气球充气一样。
I got some ice on the ankle right away, but when the pain and swelling didn't subside, and I found I could put no weight on the ankle, I decided I had to go to the emergency room. The pain in my ankle as my friend drove me to the ER was nowhere as bad as the pain in my head, already I had visions of needing surgery and being incapacitated for a long period of time. I desperately wanted to believe my injury wasn't serious. When I got to the ER, the triage nurse took one look at my ballooned ankle and told me it was broken. I argued with her and told her the pain wasn't that bad. When someone took my blood pressure and found that
我立刻在脚踝上敷了冰，但当疼痛和肿胀没有消退，我发现脚踝无法承受任何重量时，我决定必须去急诊室。朋友开车送我去急诊室时，脚踝的疼痛远没有我头脑中的疼痛严重，我已经想象着需要手术并长期丧失行动能力。我拼命想相信我的伤并不严重。当我到达急诊室时，分诊护士看了一眼我肿胀的脚踝，告诉我它骨折了。我跟她争辩，告诉她疼痛没那么严重。当有人测量我的血压并发现
it was high, I insisted they measure it again until they got a lower reading. I didn't think of it at the time, but what I was experiencing was information aversion. I knew I had hurt myself, but I didn't want to know how badly. As it turned out, the ankle wasn't broken, it was just a very bad sprain. In the grand scheme of things, an ankle sprain is a trivial problem. It isn't cancer, or heart disease, or a serious infection. It isn't bankruptcy, or lack losing a job. But it may be realized that if I could experience information a version for something so small, it's hardly surprising that people experience much more information aversion when the stakes are higher. People who avoid
它很高时，我坚持让他们再测一次，直到得到一个较低的读数。我当时没想那么多，但我经历的正是信息厌恶。我知道我伤到了自己，但我不想知道伤得有多重。事实证明，脚踝没有骨折，只是严重的扭伤。从宏观角度来看，脚踝扭伤是一个微不足道的问题。它不是癌症、心脏病或严重的感染。它不是破产或失业。但它让我意识到，如果我能对这么小的事情产生信息厌恶，那么当风险更高时，人们经历更严重的信息厌恶也就不足为奇了。人们回避
information rationally know that they would be better off if they fully understood the bad news. You should always be willing to hear information about your finances or your health. But deep in the brain, there are rules that tell us to avoid things that are unpleasant, painful, or scary. Like listeners Jason, Annie, and Nancy, we shut out the news we'd rather not hear. If we want people to pay attention to negative information, we can't assume that they will behave like rational robots. We have to communicate information accurately,
信息，理性地知道如果他们完全了解坏消息会更好。“你应该总是愿意听取关于你的财务或健康的信息。”但在大脑深处，有一些规则告诉我们要避免令人不快、痛苦或可怕的事情。像听众杰森、安妮和南希一样，我们屏蔽了我们不想听到的新闻。如果我们想让人们关注负面信息，我们不能假设他们会像理性的机器人一样行事。我们必须准确地传达信息，
but also give people the capacity to process and deal with psychological pain. Fighting the ostrich effect means fighting a myth. Avoiding information doesn't mean you're a fool. It means you're human. It means you're human. This week's episode was produced by Path Shah. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle and Alti Bandle Moody. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle.
但也给人们处理和应对心理痛苦的能力。对抗鸵鸟效应意味着对抗一个神话。回避信息并不意味着你是个傻瓜。这意味着你是人类。这意味着你是人类。本周的剧集由帕斯·沙制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和阿尔蒂·班德尔·穆迪。我们的监制是塔拉·博伊尔。
Our unsung hero this week is Sarah Gilbert. She's the acting VP of News and Operations at NPR and she plays an important role in getting NPR shows on the air. She is an effective leader, decisive and clear and she is always empathic to the concerns of people around her. She is British and she tends to call people Ducky. I thought I'd return the favor today. Thanks Ducky.
我们本周的无名英雄是莎拉·吉尔伯特。她是 NPR 新闻和运营的代理副总裁，她在让 NPR 节目播出方面发挥了重要作用。她是一位有效的领导者，果断而清晰，并且她总是对周围人的担忧感同身受。她是英国人，倾向于称呼人们为“Ducky”（亲爱的）。我想今天我也回敬一下。谢谢，Ducky。
For more hidden brain, you can find us on Twitter and Facebook. If you know someone who would like our YouTube.com series, please tell them about our show. Next week, our series continues with an episode about marriage. When we should ask for more from our partners, and when we should ask for less. All of us have an actual self, the person that we currently are. But we also have an ideal self, a version of ourselves that's aspirational. We look to our partners to be our sculptors, to help us, until we actually grow toward the best ideal version of ourselves.
想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在 Twitter 和 Facebook 上找到我们。如果你认识喜欢我们 YouTube.com 系列节目的人，请告诉他们我们的节目。下周，我们的系列节目将继续，这一集关于婚姻。我们什么时候应该向伴侣要求更多，什么时候应该要求更少。我们每个人都有一个现实的自我，即我们目前的样子。但我们也有一个理想的自我，一个我们渴望成为的版本。我们期待伴侣成为我们的雕塑家，帮助我们，直到我们真正成长为我们理想中的最佳版本。
I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. and this is his NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是 NPR。这是他的 NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。